morning all the fallouts from those
downing street lockdown parties
continues with four of boris johnson's
senior aides leaving in a mass exodus
from number 10. meanwhile the chancellor
rishi sunnah widely touted as a possible
successor to the prime minister well
he's been adding to the pressure on the
pm over the run about jimmy savile and
the leader of the labour party well
overnight the conservatives did win the
south end west by-election with one
conservative mp telling sky news that
people were worried about the cost of
living and just wanted boris johnson to
get on with running the country from
south end our chief political
correspondent john craig reports
and i do hereby declare that annalisa
is duly elected
brief respite from the turmoil in
downing street for boris johnson as the
conservatives held south end west early
this morning in the by-election caused
by the stabbing of popular veteran mp
sir david amos in october but tories
here admitted the partygate scandal
engulfing the prime minister
calls for him to quit and the cost of
living crisis were raised by voters on
the doorstep people are worried about
cost of living the announcement rishi's
made are in the right direction but you
know some of that by one saying you know
for god's sake tell boris just to get on
and run the country
back at westminster mps claimed the near
meltdown in 10 downing street after an
exodus of four members of the pm's inner
circle in one day has further increased
pressure on the embattled premier
their chief of staff dan rosenfield
blamed by some for allowing a drinking
culture in number 10.
martin reynolds dubbed party marty after
writing the notorious bring your own
booze email
and director of communications jack
doyle said to have attended at least one
of the parties under investigation
the fourth policy chief manira merza
resigned bitterly attacking the pm over
his claim that sakia stammer failed to
prosecute jimmy savile that claim also
prompted a rebuke from rishi sunak in a
move seen as distancing himself from mr
johnson ahead of a leadership contest
with regard to their comments
in you know being being honest i
wouldn't have said it and i'm glad that
the prime minister clarified what he
meant
and the chancellor has turned up the
heat on the pm in an article in today's
sun
we have always been the party of sound
money he writes we will always continue
to be on my watch
and that is the only kind of party i am
interested in after what boris johnson's
critics claim has been a chaotic week in
downing street because labour and the
liberal democrats were not standing in
this by-election the conservatives were
always going to win by a landslide but
the big battle for votes for the prime
minister now is with those mps who want
to oust him
the pm will hope his downing street
shake-up which took place while voters
here were going to the polls will buy
him some time
john craig sky news south end
lots to talk about then uh pleased to
say the minister for energy clean growth
and climate change greg hans joins us in
the studio morning see you in the flesh
minister um
and i think you know where we're going
to start this morning four very very
senior individuals in number 10 have
left or or about to leave with the
greatest respect just what the hell is
going on in number 10 at the moment
well
let's not forget that on monday the
prime minister when responding
to the sugree report update made clear
that there would be changes
at the top in number 10 resignations
have been made resignations have been
accepted these are all people who've
done fantastic service to the country
throughout the pandemic in almost all of
those cases and we should be thankful
for them for their service but the prime
minister was absolutely clear on monday
uh that there will be changes at the top
in number 10 and that is what he's
delivered what will three of the
resignations may well be a response to
sue graham and you know moser who we'll
talk about in a second that has nothing
to do with that but in terms of the
three that you identify as a response to
the sue gray update why didn't the prime
minister wait for the metropolitan
police to conclude their investigation
well because he was clear on monday that
there would be changes to the operation
yeah obviously he was going to do those
immediately obviously he said he did say
and and i have to admit it's it's been
the mantra from government for many
weeks now wait for sue gray sue gray
provided an update then it was wait for
the metropolitan police investigation to
conclude hasn't the prime minister in
accepting these resignations or perhaps
even pushing for them simply you know
drawn conclusions that he shouldn't have
done before the met had done their job
no i disagree with that this is about
the prime minister uh saying that there
were the sugray uh report update said
that there were
failings at the top at the top of the
operation uh this is the prime minister
taking charge is a wider issue than just
the sue gray report it's actually saying
that we need changes at number 10 which
is what the prime minister said he would
deliver on monday okay so who are
replacing the chief of staff then who's
replacing the chief of staff well i
understand that dan rosenfield is
carrying on until such a time as he is
replaced uh we will see you know i would
expect the prime minister to appoint a
very very capable person
or capable people in those roles it is
after all a great honor
to work at number 10 and to serve your
country and i'd expect very capable
people to be in there so the only the
only problem with that analysis is that
if this was part of some carefully
thought out and constructed plan surely
you would have the names of those who
would be replacing them ready to go
isn't the simple fact of the matter that
the prime minister rushed out a couple
of resignations that were planned for
next week because manira and merza
marched out the front gate number 10.
well the the resignation of manira musa
is a little bit different i accept that
she made clear her reasons for her
resignation the prime minister equally
clear that he disagreed with her but
nonetheless manir is somebody who's put
in an amazing service i know as a london
mp
the incredible role she's played for
boris johnson both as mayor of london
now as prime minister
and we shouldn't leave without paying
tribute to the amazing work that she's
done um for the people of london the
people of the country over the past 15
years sure well let's let let's not
gloss over why uh mineral murder quit
number 10. there are suggesting that
there are plenty of other reasons rather
than those stated but let's just take a
quick look at the stated reasons if we
can bring up that graphic
uh she says this i believe it was wrong
for you to imply this week that
kierstarma was personally responsible
for allowing jimmy sabal to escape
justice there was no fair or reasonable
basis for that assertion she continues
you're a better man than many of your
detractors will ever understand which is
why it is so desperately sad that you
let yourself down by making a scurrilous
accusation against the leader of the
opposition and it's not even not just
manira mirza who feels that the prime
minister spoke out of turn uh in linking
jimmy savile to keir starmer here's what
the chancellor had to say on this
particular topic yesterday
regard to their comments
in you know being being honest i
wouldn't have said it and i'm glad that
the prime minister clarified what he
meant
so you've got manitoba murder resigning
over this the chancellor's saying he
wouldn't have said it simon clark of
course saying that he believed it was an
entirely reasonable remark would you
have said it
uh look the prime minister was clear
yesterday in response to monira mirza's
resignation that he disagrees at the
basis of her resignation what she had to
say the prime minister was also clear on
wednesday that he was referring back to
the public apology
made by saquia starmer and i think it
was 2013 and it was all about a wider
thing about taking responsibility uh for
an organization for the faith you've
said in an organization would you have
said it in the way that the prime
minister did protected by parliamentary
privileges privilege at pmq's well look
the prime minister said that he
disagreed yesterday with the basis of
the resignation of what manila mirza had
to say and that that i think is the end
of the matter well it's not the end of
the matter because i'm going to ask the
question for a third time would you have
said it
look i'm saying the prime minister
disagreed with what she had to say that
is the important thing here uh these are
all events that happened many many years
ago the time is now to move on and look
at what the country wants us to focus on
which is recovery from the pandemic
further vaccination roll out
move to net zero the energy transition i
get i get the impression i'm not going
to make much headway on that particular
question so let's do that which you ask
and move on to the measures which the
chancellor was announcing yesterday you
know measures which i'm sure plenty of
people will warmly welcome extra money
as we see the cost of
living sore but let's just look at a
couple of the the ways in which the
chancellor described the council tax
money and the energy at cap money
yesterday let's just have a quick look
at what he said yesterday he said this
it's a flat rate a flat 200 pounds and a
flat 150 pounds that's obviously going
to mean more to families on lower
incomes or with lower energy bills so in
that sense it's a progressive measure
that will help those family more has
wishes soon that just redefined
progressive
no i sat next to him in the house
commons
when he made the announcement yesterday
as we know energy bills i'm the energy
minister are quite regressive
therefore the more that you can provide
for those
on lower middle incomes the better that
is why we've also done things like the
rise in the national living wage from
eight pounds 91 an hour to nine pounds
fifty an hour giving somebody on the
national living wage an extra one
thousand pounds in their pay packet
these council tax rises for those living
in bands a to d
uh and also the households on energy
with the energy bills that a 200 pound
discount on their energy bills all of
these will give a lot of help to those
not just on low incomes but also middle
incomes who are going to be hit by the
rise in energy bills that will come in
from april but it's just that whenever
politicians have used the term
progressive in the past particularly
progressive taxation or so on it's a
measure which takes into account the
circumstances of the individual affected
this this pays no attention certainly
the 200 pounds towards energy bills pays
absolutely no heat to the individual
circumstances does it well look the
overall package so things like the
council tax
rebate for those living in bands a to d
properties there's also 144 million
pounds for local authorities
to deal with people who for example are
in low income but have high energy bills
these are all very progressive measures
as of course as the national living wage
increase and the changes in the
universal credit taper rate all of these
will actually really help people on low
and middle incomes
again i'll just make the point it
doesn't strike me as particularly
progressive to be handing out to
everyone those who desperately need it
and those who perhaps do not desperately
need it 200 pounds but but more than
that why are we describing it as a
rebate when it is pretty clearly alone
okay it is a discount first of all
you've got to look at in terms of
whether the message
whether the whole set of measures are
progressive you've got to look at all of
the measures that were announced by the
chancellor yesterday and at the budget
in november we are describing the energy
bill uh change as a discount the council
tax is a rebate the council tax gets
given to 200 pounds one-off will not be
repaid uh the 200 pounds on energy bills
is a discount because that will be
repaid by the bill pair but over a
five-year period that's quite a long
period of time to be able to repay that
the the reason for the five-year period
as i understand it is by that point you
seem fairly certain that that is when
wholesale prices energy prices may have
returned to normal no i'm not i'm not
predicting energy prices sure but what
we are saying about energy price has
been incredibly volatile of course of
course you know they're four to five
times the average over the last 25 years
at the moment but they're actually
equally half the peak so energy prices
are very volatile we're not doing a
prediction energy prices what we are
saying is that people need help now
which is why we are giving people the
200 pound discount which will come in
october but it's certainly been
mentioned by those in government that
2024 is a point by which you know
wholesale the wholesale prices market
may well have just calmed down a little
bit that certainly there's been
something that's said so i'm wondering
with energy prices expected to remain at
high levels for a number of years is
this a one-off it can't be a one-off can
it well we'll have to see what the
decisions of the future in relation uh
to energy you're not ruling it out
you're not suggesting that this is a
one-off payment and that's it there may
be future assistance it is my job to
make sure the country is prepared on all
things related to energy it's not my job
to make uh if you like energy price
forecasts for the future energy prices
have been elevated for the last nine
months or so they've also been very
volatile in that time that is why we're
bringing in that support right up front
the nine billion pound package of
support announced by the chancellor
yesterday in response to energy price
rises and other price rises coming in
this year but just but just on on the
council tax rebates i mean the times
describes it as loopy and lopsided the
point that they make london boroughs
with huge property prices will receive
the same as properties in the midlands
and the north indeed that actually pay
hundreds more in council tax
again not progressive well that's why
we've got the 144 million pounds extra
for local authorities to look at those
cases where somebody is on low income
but has a high energy bill eg living in
a high value property that will be in
council tax bans uh e and above
that's also why that fund is there also
for people who don't pay council tax
people on very low incomes who don't pay
cancer tax at all that is why we have
the 144 million pound local authority
fund why does the prime minister
seemingly not pay any heed to the optics
of what he is doing at the moment i mean
let's just reflect on what happened
yesterday the bank of england told us
that we're in for a record slight in
living standards that you know the
governor of the bank of england himself
on roughly what in excess of 500 grand a
year tells us all not to ask for big pay
rises on that day the prime minister to
an event in blackpool takes a private
plane
well look
i i can promise you the prime minister
travels by train a lot uh i see him on
the train he he
going by train is is like
prime minister loves training buses
one of them but let's trust taking the
plane to australia
the prime minister's had a difficult
schedule this week don't forget you know
he's had responded to the sugray uh uh
update on monday he's been to the
ukraine on tuesday
that is a long distance 50 minutes off
his journey but he's
hold on but he's come back on wednesday
to answer prime minister's questions in
the house comments on thursday he's in
blackpool that is a difficult schedule
for anybody at the best of themselves
and i know the prime minister and he is
somebody who instinctively loves public
transport that's what i saw when he was
mayor of london i was one of his mps in
london he is somebody who loves public
transport but has been a difficult you
would agree that's a difficult
challenging schedule this week for him
minister great to have you on the
program this morning thank you for
joining us
now a quick run through the front pages
of the newspapers that we have uh
because we've got all of them in fact at
the guardian leading on those
resignations at number 10 after four of
boris johnson's key aides left their
post
meltdown in downing street that's the
front of the mail it says the departure
of manira mirza left the prime minister
in shock
the eye says it was the day boris
johnson's top team quit number 10 on
mass
both the chancellor and the bank of
england setting out measures to tackle
the cost of living crisis the ft is
reporting that disposable incomes in the
uk are at their tightest for 30 years
and the metro caused the announcement of
those plans and the
fiscal strife that many people are
facing a perfect storm
and just a reminder that on monday at
nine o'clock k burley will be joined by
this chat the education secretary nadeem
zahali answering all your questions you
can send them in via twitter you can
send a video clip
or email ask the education secretary at
sky dot uk
still to come on the show this morning
a winter olympics like no other will be
getting a chinese perspective on the
beijing games
then at eight o'clock i'll be joined by
the shadow secretary of state for
climate change and net zero ed miliband
and a little later on i'll be speaking
to the oldest pair of roars
to cross the atlantic
[Music]
rescue teams have been working around
the clock to save a five-year-old boy
who fell down a hundred foot well in
morocco they are now within feet of him
but there are concerns about his safety
because of the freezing temperatures
skies kamali melbourne reports
five-year-old rayanne has been trapped
100 feet down a narrow well for three
days the rescue effort has been frantic
i managed to communicate with the child
and asked if he could hear me
there was a response
i waited for a minute and saw that he
began using the oxygen
i then asked to be lifted back and in
the first attempt i failed
in the second attempt i lost
consciousness especially in the last 10
meters
until i woke and found people
administering first aid on me
it happened in the northern moroccan
village of igrad huge excavators are now
at work stripping away the earth
a camera was lowered showing ryan alive
he's been given oxygen and water through
pipes and his family can only wait
i prayed to god and begged him to get
him out of that well alive and safe
please god ease my pain and his in that
hole of dust
the rescue has gripped the nation and
the region hashtag save ryan has been
trending a local government spokesman
said his rescue is approaching
kamali melbourne sky news
let's return to the crisis in ukraine
now and the united states has claimed
that russia is preparing to stage a fake
attack on its own troops in order to
justify an invasion of ukraine
as part of this um
fake attack
we believe that russia would produce a
very graphic propaganda video
which would include corpses
and actors that would be depicting
mourners and images of destroyed
locations
as well as military equipment
at the hands of ukraine or the west
well in the last hour or so president
vladimir putin has arrived in china for
talks with president xi jinping
our asia correspondent tom cheshire
joins us now from beijing morning tom
good to see you um so what is on the
table for discussion then
morning neil a lot on the table for
discussion they haven't seen each other
for two years because president xi
jinping hasn't received any world leader
for two years uh luckily it is vladimir
putin who's he's described as his best
friend and the situation on ukraine will
be top of the agenda they've chinese and
russian foreign ministries have said
they've already coordinated their
position but i think we'll see some
specifics come out of that in terms of
trade deals in terms of energy deals uh
president putin talked about this in an
editorial he wrote for chinese state
media
talking about energy supplies to china
that could be very useful in the context
of ukraine if gas supplies to europe are
cut this is another revenue stream not
just in the short term but in the long
term to prop up the russian economy and
they said they'd already been working on
how to mitigate the impact of unilateral
sanctions a reference uh to the package
of sanctions that the u.s is preparing
uh in the event of a russian invasion um
so it does look like they are one front
chinese state media described them as
standing back to back against their
opponents and it does feel like a moment
you won't have any western leaders at
the opening ceremony for this olympics
but you will have putin and xi sitting
side by side in the front row perhaps
representing a new world order at least
a marriage of convenience and there have
been questions about whether as a result
of the olympics putin would invade would
she ask his very good friend vladimir
putin not to spoil his ceremony not to
reign on his parade because there's a
lot of work that's gone into this all
eyes will be on beijing uh this evening
local time afternoon time in the uk as
those uh olympics kick off um that might
be the case there may be some olympic
truce but i think both these countries
look after their own interests first
before anything else and one thing to
remember is that back in 2008 the first
olympics in beijing the summer olympics
the eve of that opening ceremony was the
same evening we got reports the first
reports of russian troops moving into
georgia so it's not a done deal but this
is a real burgeoning friendship i think
they'll be on full display when we get a
few pictures later
tom ford thanks for watching indeed
uh now the pentagon has said the killing
of the leader of islamic state has dealt
a significant blow to the terrorist
group abu ibrahim al-hashemi al-qureshi
detonated the bomb which killed him his
wife and his children
after being targeted by u.s special
forces in northwestern syria
the health secretary sajid javid will
announce today a new 10-year plan to
improve england's cancer care during the
pandemic there have been 50 000 fewer
cancer diagnoses across the uk risking
an increase in advanced cases which are
harder to treat
our correspondent ashley horonic joins
us now from the newsroom good morning to
you
take us through what we're expecting to
hear from the health secretary then
yeah of course first of all i mean 50
000 fewer cases of cancer being picked
up across the uk over the past couple of
years that is despite of course cancer
services remaining a top priority for
the nhs but this is a plan uh being
outlined by the health secretary to try
and overhaul the way that cancer care is
delivered in england he's going to want
to hear from people who have experienced
that care themselves so cancer patients
relatives of those that have got loved
ones that have had cancer but also nhs
workers the whole plan really is to
culminate this 10-year at this 10-year
booster program to try and improve the
way that it's tackled boosting the
cancer workforce is what he wants to do
increasing research into new
technologies things like proton beam
therapy but also bolstering vaccine
capabilities we've seen what vaccines
can do over the pandemic he thinks that
they there could be scope to strengthen
the way that cancer is is uh treated
through vaccines the call for evidence
opens today neil and that structure for
that 10-year plan will be outlined at
the end of the year cancer is the
biggest cause of death in the uk and
this is one way the health secretary
plans to overhaul it
ashley thank you
now northern ireland's first minister
powell given his resigned from
stormont's power sharing executive in
protest against post-brexit border
checks uh let's head to our island
correspondent stephen murphy uh joining
us from belfast from just outside storm
in fact good to see you this morning
steven looks a bit chilly where you are
tell us exactly what on earth is going
on here why the resignation because of
course it means
not just the first minister going but
the deputy first minister as well
yeah it's freezing here neil
yes we've been here before and we're
here again as of this morning northern
ireland doesn't have a fully functioning
devolved government paul given as you
said there the first minister the dup
first minister stepping down last night
and that automatically triggers the
resignation of michelle o'neill the
deputy first minister from sinn fein as
well because it's a joint office so
without a first minister or a deputy
first
minister the executive uh which sits
here at storm and cannot meet so
effectively the government is going to
limp on at the moment
the other ministers will remain in their
posts um but they have one hand tied
behind their back they can't conduct any
new business for example the health
minister robin swan is taking legal
advice at the moment to establish what
exactly his current powers are they're
supposed to be a meeting next week to
discuss getting rid of northern
ireland's existing coronavirus
restrictions and now nobody knows if
that is going to go ahead and that's an
example i suppose of how all this
political maneuvering has a real impact
on the people of northern ireland
ordinary people here watching all these
uh political jousting with a sort of
familiar sense of resignation it wasn't
that long ago that northern ireland went
three years until january 2020 without a
fully functioning executive now it's
slightly different this time around
under the current rules there there's a
seven day period uh for those posts to
be
fulfilled before the whole thing comes
collapsing down but at the moment
there's legislation going through
westminster next week which will extend
that for a period of six to nine months
and that brings us up to the election
which is currently scheduled here in
northern ireland for the fifth of may
shin fein they're furious with the dup
they have called for an election to be
brought forward possibly as early as the
middle of march and the dup leader
jeffrey donaldson last night effectively
saying bring it on uh he's saying it is
time for the people to have their say
and at the heart of all of this is the
dep's anger with the post-brexit checks
the so-called northern ireland protocol
which established an irish sea border
and the important thing to remember is
even though
this dramatic move went ahead last night
it has done nothing to affect that that
irish sea border is still in place the
checks even though the dup minister in
charge tried to scrap them we believe
we're still going ahead
at least until next monday and against
all of this the negotiations on the
protocol are still going on between the
eu and the uk the eu have called all of
this extremely unwelcome
stephen you go and warm yourself up
we'll speak again soon for now thanks
very much indeed
time for us to have a check on the
weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and you may have noticed already today
looking cold and windy with sunshine and
wintry showers but much of the south
will start wet
early rain spreading across southern
britain will turn to sleet or snow in
places before clearing into the
southeast elsewhere a more showery start
with a slight covering of snow on some
hills it will be windy and cold for many
with icy stretches in the northeast a
reminder as to our top stories the
energy minister
greg hans has told sky news breakfast
that the departure of four senior aides
from number 10 shows that boris johnson
is taking charge
the united states claims that russia is
plotting a fake attack to justify an
invasion of ukraine as president putin
arrives in beijing for talks with the
chinese president
and the health secretary is to announce
a new 10-year plan to improve england's
cancer care after 50 000 fewer diagnoses
were made during the pandemic
well the fallout from the downing street
lockdown parties continues with four of
boris johnson's most senior aides
leaving in a mass exodus from number 10.
within the last half an hour the energy
minister greg hans told me that the
prime minister is the one in control of
the situation
this is about the prime minister uh
saying that they were the sugray uh
report update said that there were
failings at the top at the top of the
operation uh this is the prime minister
taking charge is a wider issue than just
uh the su grey report it's actually
saying that we need changes at number 10
which is what the prime minister said he
would deliver on monday
let's bring in our political
correspondent joe pike who has stood
outside number 10 for us good to see joe
what are we to make of that i suppose
you could just about argue that the
prime minister was taking charge
clearing house responding to the su-grey
update were it not for the fact that
monera murder wandered out the front
door of number 10 saying that this was
entirely to do with jimmy savile
exactly neil part of what happened
yesterday was boris johnson taking
charge because the three men and senior
royals who have left were effectively
sacked because they mishandled uh the
fallout of the party gate row and they
needed to go a lot of mps wanted them to
go but as you say manira merza who was
the head of policy here at downing
street quit she resigned because she was
so angry about that to jimmy savile guy
than kierstarma that boris johnson
yesterday
sort of sent me you turned on but didn't
actually fully apologize it also
suggests one that there's been an
argument on that issue for three days
here but also that there are tensions
and have been tensions between ms merza
and the prime minister probably for a
number of weeks or months and this was
the final straw the other significant
thing that the minister touched on and
happened yesterday was that comment from
rishi sunak here at downing street news
conference giving his own view
on the pm's jimmy savile kiyostama jibe
saying he wouldn't have said it although
he didn't say that boris johnson
necessarily should have apologized that
i think neil is the sign of a fisher a
small split at the very top of
government of course if that develops
into a bigger wider gap it really could
be problematic for the prime minister
joe thank you
now china has promised a winter olympics
to remember despite of course the
continuing difficulties caused by the
kofi pandemic the opening ceremony takes
place in beijing in just a few hours
time victor gao is the vice president of
the center for china and globalization
very pleased to say he joins us now from
beijing victor great to have you on the
program this morning you must be
incredibly excited ahead of the the
opening ceremony
absolutely the opening seminar ceremony
is about four hours from now and i think
the whole chinese nation are looking
forward to this glorious display of
olympic
tradition and i think the whole world is
also holding its breath to see what will
happen on this very spectacular day of
the opening ceremony for the beijing
winter olympics and beijing will be
carved into history as the only city
which has hosted both the winter
olympics as well as the summer olympics
so this is a very extraordinary day for
china and for the whole world
of course major sporting events
particularly the olympics do try to
separate out the sporting achievement of
the athletes from perhaps broader
political concerns but the fact that
britain the united states and canada are
all partaking in diplomatic boycotts of
the winter olympics because they're
being held in beijing that that does
somewhat take the sheen off the event
well i feel very sorry for those uh
western country leaders who decided not
to
come to attend the beijing winter
olympics i think such so-called
diplomatic boycott is really parking at
the wrong tree and it's not
consequential at all i've equated that
to the equivalent of launching a hunger
strike after your dinner until breakfast
in the morning it will not change or
impact upon the beijing winter olympics
and i think
these western leaders will feel sorry
once they see the glory and the
spectacular display of the olympic
spirit starting tonight and for the
coming two weeks and then another two
weeks
then i think they will feel sorry about
their
absence from the beijing winter olympics
would athletes be permitted then to make
political statements
well olympics has its tradition and
discipline olympic occasion is not a
place for politics and i hope athletes
from everywhere in the world including
from the united states and the united
kingdom will abide by the olympic
tradition and will focus on the sports
activities and try to excel among their
peers rather than being diverted into
political activities olympic
game is not the appropriate place to do
politics
still in the margins it often takes
place we know of course that vladimir
putin is flying in and i'm certain that
he will be very interested in the
sporting achievements that are on
display but also his meeting with xi
jinping will be of pivotal importance
what what do you make
of the suggestions that we are at the
beginning once again of a cold war
president putin of russia has already
arrived in beijing he's preparing to
attend the opening ceremony which will
start eight o'clock tonight beijing time
he will be one of the about 30
world leaders from different countries
and from the united nations in the form
of the secretary general guterres and i
think the gathering of the global
leaders for the beijing
olympics will be about three times more
than the gathering of world leaders
attending the tokyo summer olympics so
talking about the diplomatic boycott
it's not consequential at all however it
is true that the beijing winter olympics
takes place at a very critical time in
global geopolitics
and i think the crisis surrounding
ukraine is really making the whole world
very jittery i hope president putin and
president xi jinping of china will have
time to talk about what exactly is
happening and we'll be able to come up
with more concerted actions because
we do not want to see a war unfolding in
ukraine and i still believe that peace
and diplomacy will prevail it is not
time for europe or for asia to plunge
into war that is really against the
fundamental interest of countries and
people everywhere in the world
well victor let's both of us then park
the politics just for one second so i
can ask you just finally we are looking
forward to the sporting events
themselves which athletes are you
looking forward to seeing particularly
if they might not come from where are
you from
well
i believe
the beijing winter olympics will be the
best occasion for athletes very good at
winter sports to compete and excel and
traditionally you have several countries
which are very good in winter sports
countries like
norway canada the united states and
sometimes the united kingdom for example
they have very deep traditions about
winter sports switzerland is another one
austria and italy for example
traditionally china is not very strong
in winter
sports however i think the beijing
winter olympics will be the occasion for
rallying
hundreds of millions of the chinese and
it is expected about 300 million chinese
will become fans of winter sports and
this will be a big boost for winter
sports of all kinds in china it will be
a big boost to the international olympic
movement and i think whichever athletes
from whichever country who wins the
medals will be chaired by the audience
here in china and they will be chaired
by their countrymen and the leaders of
their governments throughout the world
and it's encouraging to see that
president biden of the united states
already promised that he will be
watching the opening ceremony of the
beijing olympics not personally here in
beijing but
on television
good to have you on the program this
morning enjoy the games and thanks for
joining us
thank you very much for having me
the uk's medicines and healthcare
regulator has given researchers the
go-ahead to study the therapeutic
effects of medical cannabis on patients
suffering from long covet scientists
believe it could help to relieve things
such as fatigue and breathlessness it's
believed the condition affects around
one in seven people who've contracted
covert 19. we're joining us now on the
program kyle esplan who himself has been
receiving medical cannabis to treat a
post-viral condition and dr elizabeth
iverson the principal investigator of
the study at drug science kyle elizabeth
lovely to have you both on the program
this morning um but doctor i i wonder if
we might start from you just just
explain the reason for this study what
is it you are trying to establish
um thanks for having me on um where
as part of my work as a stroke and your
rehabilitation physician i treat many
patients that have
um
a consolation of lots of different
symptoms such as fatigue um
sleeplessness
insomnia
and pain
and
i've also have patients that have um
fatigue related to post viral symptoms
um so this
and
medical cannabis um
i've used as a potent as a tool to try
to
help that some of these symptoms which
are very similar to the patients i'm
seeing now presenting with um long
covered
which is again an umbrella term for a
collection of symptoms
which as you said includes fatigue
breathlessness and muscle aches and
muscle weakness
um so this study is looking to see
whether medical cannabis in the form of
an oil
has the potential to try and improve
symptoms and and improve quality of life
of those
patients that i have symptoms of lung
coverage
sure kyle we will come to you in just a
second but just before we do doctor what
is it about cannabis or medical cannabis
i should be specific
that may well help with conditions like
this what are the properties
involved
yeah so so cannabis is a um
again it's quite a broad term to
describe a plant which contains lots of
different molecules and and
consist um
and things that
the cannabis plant contains lots of
different
um molecules in it
there's over 144 cannabinoids for
example in the plant and there's many
different strains of cannabis and types
of cannabis and some of those types of
cannabis when given um carefully and
prescribed and supervised
um can have quite uplifting stimulating
properties and help with fatigue
um
the the the
cbd particularly which is the um
dominant property of the cannabis oil
that we're using um
has shown to be quite stimulating and
and helps with fatigue um it can also
help with sleep
and pain as well
um and it's to do with the the different
properties within the cannabis plant um
that that can help
with these symptoms
um kyle i mean
as mentioned you've been taking medical
cannabis since i think 2019 but you
developed a condition what way way
before that didn't you just tell us a
little bit about the the struggles that
you've had
good morning thanks for having me on
there so my background's in the
entertainment industry and back in 2012
i was traveling the world having a great
life doing a high energy stage shows and
i was performing on a cruise ship when i
was struck down by a respiratory viral
infection
and it was a viral infection like i'd
never had before my health deteriorated
severely and it continued to deteriorate
over a period of six months and i went
from being a high energy
individual to someone who was unable to
look after myself i couldn't bathe
couldn't wash and i needed care and
there was no medical
no no medical options available to bring
me back to life to bring back
functionality at the time and i'm so
pleased that medical cannabis has come
up and getting this attention now in the
research it deserves to to bring this to
be available to more people to be able
to benefit also
sure but tell us then just just in what
way did medical cannabis improve your
quality of life because it sounds like
it was pretty grim for a time
so i got a long list of symptoms one of
the worst one is a post-exertional
malaise which is these relapses which
prevent you from recovering so you know
i was already suffering from extreme
pain extreme fatigue extreme intolerance
of
of
new allergies develop
everything was
was dysfunctional and when i started
using cannabis as medicine it's like it
turned down the volume on all the
symptoms and they just all quietened
down and they allowed my body to heal
and recover and regain strength and i
was able to regain a level of physical
fitness and functionality that i never
expected i was going to achieve
well i'm very pleased that that it has
had such a positive effect um dr iverson
we're just about to run out of time but
but at what point do you think this
clinical trial that this trial will be
at an end when do we expect to hear some
conclusions from your research
yeah i mean the trial's running for six
months from um
from from now um so we would expect to
hear um some outcomes um within the next
five to six months
um
and
the patients are going to be monitored
very carefully um
and hopefully we'll have this will
hopefully lead on to a a bigger trial in
the future of the
safety and tolerability of medical
cannabis and longevity is demonstrated
we will keep fingers crossed on your
behalf dr elizabeth iverson carl esplin
great to have you in the program this
morning
[Music]